>> IT WAS A REJECTION ELECTION,
VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY REJECTED THESE RADICAL
POLICIES OF THE DEMOCRATS WHICH
HAVE CAUSED INFLATION, RISING
PRICES, OPEN BORDERS AND NOW
THEY WANT TO RAISE TAXES EVEN
HIGHER.
YOU WOULD THINK THIS WOULD BE A
WAKE-UP CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS
BUT THEY’RE STILL SLEEP WALKING
LIKE ZOMBIES ON THIS ROAD TO
SOCIALISM.
JASON:  THAT WAS WYOMING SENATOR
AND GOP CONFERENCE CHAIR, JOHN
BAR A RASE SEWBARRASSO ON THIS P
THIS MONTH AFTER REPUBLICAN
GLENN YOUNGKIN WON THE RACE IN
BLUE STATE VIRGINIA AND NEW
JERSEY’S GOVERNOR BARELY HELD
ONTO HIS SEAT.
OUR NEXT GUEST AIMS TO KEEP THE
RED WAVE GOING.
MINNESOTA CONGRESSMAN TOM EMMER
IS CHAIRMAN OF THE NATIONAL
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE AND SOMEBODY I HAD THE
HONOR AND PRIVILEGE OF SERVING
WITH IN THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.
I MEAN, REPUBLICANS ARE BOUYED
BUT I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU, THEY
HAVE A KNACK, REPUBLICANS, OF
KIND OF LOSING THAT MOMENTUM AND
GETTING OFF MESSAGE AND
SNATCHING DEFEAT FROM THE JAWS
OF VICTORY.
WHAT’S THE PLAN TO ACTUALLY GET
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE TAPE AND
TAKE BACK THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE?
>> WELL, JASON, FIRST OFF, GREAT
TO SEE YOU.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
YOU’RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
LOOK, I THINK SENATOR BARRASSO
SAID IT A FEW WEEKS AGO, I’LL
SAY IT AGAIN.
THE VOTERS ARE SMART, JASON.
AMERICANS ARE SMART.
THEY ARE REJECTING THIS
SOCIALIST BIG GOVERNMENT AGENDA.
THEY REALIZE THAT DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS RIGHT NOW ARE
COMPLETELY OUT OF TOUCH WITH
MAIN STREET AMERICA AND MIDDLE
CLASS AMERICANS AND OUR JOB OVER
THE NEXT YEAR, WE KNOW IT’S
GOING TO BE A DOG FIGHT, IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT’S VERY CLEAR
EVERY DAY THAT THEIR POLICIES,
THEIR BIG GOVERNMENT POLICIES
ARE DRIVING INFLATION, ARE
DRIVING THE CRIME WAVE ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY, ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE OPEN BORDER.
WE CAN GO THROUGH ALL KINDS OF
INCOMPETENT LEADERSHIP THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SHOWN SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
JASON:  I’VE NEVER SEEN A
NATIONAL PARTY BE SO AGGRESSIVE
AGAINST FIRST RESPONDERS, LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THE BORDER PATROL,
I.C.E.
USUALLY THIS IS WHERE WE HAVE
SOME BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BUT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN VERY YOU
AGGRESSIVE.
THAT DOESN’T SEEM TO BE THE SAME
MESSAGE THEY BROUGHT INTO 2020.
SEEMS AS IF THEY GOT THERE AND
THEY ACT AS IF THEY HAVE THIS
GREEN NEW DEAL MANDATE THAT I
DIDN’T HEAR THEM TALKING ABOUT
WITH THE VELOCITY AND THE VEER
VERACITY THAT HAD ARE NOW.
>> LOOK, JASON, IF YOU LOOK
BACK, THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
POLICIES WERE INCREDIBLY
POPULAR.
WHETHER IT WAS AMERICAN ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, WHETHER IT WAS
SAFETY AND SECURITY IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES, IN YOUR STATE, IN
THIS COUNTRY, WHETHER IT WAS A
SECURE BORDER, SOUTHERN BORDER.
I MEAN, THESE WERE EXTREMELY POP
LAUGH.
AND YOU’RE CORRECT, -- POPULAR.
YOU’RE CORRECT, THESE DEMOCRATS
CAME INTO OFFICE, BASICALLY TOOK
IT AS A MANDATE WHICH THEY’RE
TRYING TO UNDO EVERYTHING THE
LAST ADMINISTRATION DID.
WITH TERRIBLE CONSEQUENCES TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND THAT’S WHY THEY’RE GOING TO
LOSE NEXT FALL.
JASON:  ONE OF THE KEY METRICS
OUT THERE IS YOU LOOK AT
RETIREMENTS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE’S 17
DEMOCRATS THAT HAVE ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY’RE GOING TO RETIRE
THIS YEAR, COMPARED TO 12
REPUBLICANS.
AS WE TURN THE FIRST OF THE
YEAR, THIS IS USUALLY WHEN THE
MOST RETIREMENT ANNOUNCEMENTS
COME OUT.
WHAT DO YOU SEE HAPPENING THERE,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> WELL, YOU LOOK BACK AGAIN,
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO, YOU’VE GOT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHETHER IT
WAS VIRGINIA, NEW YORK, NEW
JERSEY, EVEN IN SEATTLE,
REJECTED THIS BIG GOVERNMENT
SOCIALIST AGENDA THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN PUSHING
FORWARD.
THEY REJECTED IT COMPLETELY.
AND THEY DIDN’T BACK OFF, JASON.
THEY’RE CONTINUING TO PUSH THIS
AGENDA.
BECAUSE OF THAT, YOU SEE A LOT
OF RETIREMENTS BEFORE
THANKSGIVING.
YOU MENTIONED THE 17.
A LOT OF THESE ARE LONG-TIME,
LONG-SERVING CHAIRMAN AND
CHAIRWOMAN OF THESE DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES.
LOOK, WE SAID IT BEFORE.
THE THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY, YOU’RE
RIGHT, MOST OF THESE PEOPLE GO
HOME, HAVE TIME WITH THEIR
FAMILIES, START TO REASSESS WHAT
THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE.
THEY HAVE SEEN WHAT’S COMING.
WE TOLD THEM THERE’S A DECISION
TO MAKE, RETIRE NOW OR LOSE NEXT
FALL BECAUSE REPUBLICANS WILL
TAKE BACK THE MAJORITY AND WE’RE
GOING TO FIRE NANCY PELOSI ONCE
AND FOR ALL.
JASON:  CONGRESSMAN, PLEASE STAY
RIGHT THERE.
WHEN WE COME BACK, THE WHITE
HOUSE SAYS PRESIDENT BIDEN
INTENDS TO RUN FOR RE-ELECTION
IN 2024 BUT SOME STRATEGISTS ARE
NOT SO SURE HE’LL BE UP FOR IT.
MORE AFTER THIS.
JASON:  THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
PRESIDENT BIDEN INTENDS TO RUN
FOR RE-ELECTION IN 2024 BUT
HE’LL BE 82 YEARS OLD AND HIS
APPROVAL RATINGS ARE TANKING.
SO ARE THOSE OF VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS AMID REPORTS OF
DISSENSE BETWEEN HER STAFF AND
THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE’RE BACK WITH MINNESOTA
CONGRESSMAN, TOM EMMER, CHAIR OF
THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING
THAT TEN MONTHS INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION BIDEN HAD TO
ANNOUNCE HE WAS RUNNING FOR
RE-ELECTION.
I DON’T KNOW IF THAT’S A HUGE
SELLING POINT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN A REPUBLICAN
PLANT.
WAS THAT YOUR IDEA TO GET LIMB
TO ANNOUNCE THAT IN.
>> NO, LOOK, HE CAN RUN AGAIN
IN 2024 IF THAT’S WHAT HE WANTS
TO DO BUT HE’S GOING TO LOSE,
JASON.
IT’S NOT A GOOD SIGN.
IT’S NEVER A GOOD SIGN WHEN
MEMBERS OF YOUR OWN PARTY ARE
LIT RAMLY TALKING ABOUT --
LITERALLY TALKING ABOUT WHO IS
GOING TO REPLACE YOU AND YOU
HAVEN’T BEEN IN THE JOB FOR A
FULL YEAR YET.
THE REASON THEY’RE GOING TO
LOSE, THEY’RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE INFLATION THAT WE’RE SEEING.
PRICES ARE UP FOR EVERYTHING AND
PAYCHECKS ARE DOWN.
THEY’RE RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
CRIME WAVE THAT I TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER.
THEY’RE DOING NOTHING TO SOLVE
IT, RIGHT?
AND THEY’RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
CHAOS ON OUR SOUTHERN BORDER AND
THE INCOMPETENCE JUST GOES ON
AND ON, WHETHER WE TALK ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN OR NOW THIS
RIDICULOUS POLITICAL PLOY TO
RELEASE 50 MILLION BARRELS OF
OIL FROM THE STRATEGIC PETROLEUM
OIL RESERVE.
DO PEOPLE REALIZE, JASON, THAT
THIS COUNTRY USES ABOUT 20
MILLION BARRELS A DAY?
IT’S JUST ONE INCOMPETENT MOVE
AFTER ANOTHER.
I HOPE HE DOES RUN AGAIN.
JASON:  YEAH, LESS THAN THREE
DAYS OF SUPPLY.
CONGRESSMAN, WHAT’S THE BIG
SLEEPER ISSUE THAT
DIFFERENTIATES REPUBLICANS FROM
DEMOCRATS THAT THEY THINK CAN
WIN ON NEXT YEAR?
>> LOOK, THE THINGS THAT POP,
PEOPLE DO NOT WANT MORE BIG
GOVERNMENT.
THEY WANT LESS GOVERNMENT.
WHAT DO THE DEMOCRATS DO?
THEY RUN ON BIG GOVERNMENT IN
VIRGINIA, THEY GET THEIR HAT
HANDED TO THEM.
THEY COME BACK THE NEXT DAY AND
THEY SAY THE PROBLEM IS WE
DIDN’T DO ENOUGH GOVERNMENT.
IT’S ABOUT PUTTING GOVERNMENT
INTO THE RIGHT SIZE THAT IT
SHOULD BE.
IT’S ABOUT COMPETENT LEADERSHIP.
THE INCOMPETENCE THAT WE’VE SEEN
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
IS CAUSING SERIOUS PROBLEMS FOR
MIDDLE CLASS AMERICANS, FRANKLY
FOR THE COUNTRY AS A WHOLE.
IT’S ABOUT SAFETY AND SECURITY.
IT’S ABOUT SECURITY AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THOSE ARE THE ISSUES.
IT’S ABOUT PUTTING PEOPLE,
JASON, BACK IN CHARGE OF THE
DECISIONS THEY MAKE THAT THEY
FEEL ARE BEST FOR THEMSELVES
RATHER THAN HAVING THEIR
GOVERNMENT TELL THEM WHAT THAT
IS.
JASON:  YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
THINGS I SEE THE DEMOCRATS DOING
TIME AND TIME AGAIN IS SAYING,
WELL, WE’VE GOT A MESSAGING
PROBLEM HERE.
USUALLY CONGRESSMEN WHEN THEY
START SAYING THERE’S A MESSAGING
PROBLEM IT’S BECAUSE THE POLICY
IS FAILING AND IT’S NOT
SOMETHING THEY’RE ABLE TO SELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TODAY ON SUNDAY MORNING FUTURES.
MINNESOTA CONGRESSMAN TOM EMMER